STEVE: MANY ON THE LEFT TAKING
AIM AT SWEDEN FOR ITS REFUSAL TO
COMPLETELY SHUT DOWN THEIR
ECONOMY AND THEIR COUNTRY IN THE
LIGHT OF COVID.
BUT NOW A NEW STUDY CLAIMS THAT
TARGETED LOCKDOWNS ACTUALLY SAVE
MORE LIVES AND DO LESS ECONOMIC
DAMAGE.
HERE TO DISCUSS FOX NEWS MEDICAL
CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR OF MAKE
AMERICA HEALTHY AGAIN DR. NICOLE
SAPHIER.
DR. SAPHIER, GOOD MORNING TO
YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING, STEVE.
STEVE: OKAY.
SO A COUPLE OF MIT RESEARCHERS
LOOKED AT THE NUMBERS AND
FIGURED RATHER THAN LOCK DOWN
YOUR ENTIRE ECONOMY AS WE HAVE
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, IF
YOU SIMPLY TARGETED AT THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE, PEOPLE WITH
PARTICULARLY OVER 65, YOU CAN
HAVE BETTER HEALTHCARE AND AT
THE SAME TIME YOU WON’T
OVERWHELM YOUR HOSPITALS AND YOU
DON’T BLOW UP THE ECONOMY.
>> WELL, WHILE I DO AGREE WITH A
LOT OF ASPECTS OF THIS MIT WHITE
PAPER WHICH I HAVE TO SAY HAS
NOT BEEN REVIEWED BY THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITIES YET BUT
IT IS JUST A WORKING WHITE PAPER
THEY MAKES VALID POINTS IN THE
SENSE THAT A TARGETED LOCKDOWN
IS PROBABLY GOING TO BE BETTER
FOR THE OVERALL ECONOMIC HEALTH
OF THE NATION AS WELL AS
MAINTAINING SOME OF THE PHYSICAL
HEALTH OF THE NATION.
HERE’S THE THING, STEVE, WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER THAT THE INITIAL
LOCKDOWNS OF MARCH AND APRIL
THAT WERE SO RESTRICTIVE WAS TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR HEALTH SYSTEM
HAD TIME TO CATCH UP TO THE
INFLUX OF COVID-19 PATIENTS.
HEALTH SYSTEMS SYSTEMS AT MAX
CAPACITY FROM FLU AND ILLNESS.
THEY COULDN’T TAKE IN ALL THE
PEOPLE FROM COVID-19 IT WASN’T
JUST PEOPLE OVER 65 THAT HAD TO
GO INTO THE HOSPITAL.
WE HAD WIDE HAVE VARIETY OF AGES
OUR HOSPITAL.
NOW THAT HEALTH SYSTEMS HAVE
CAUGHT UP.
WE HAVE ENOUGH PPE AND
VENTILATORS NOW IS THE TIME YOU
START LOOKING AT THE MORE OF THE
TARGETED APPROACH TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE AS WE GO INTO
THE FALL, THOSE OVER THE AGE OF
THOSE WITH PREREX CYSTING
CONDITIONS AND THOSE OVERWEIGHT.
WHILE THE REST GET BACK TO WORK.
AS WE SAW IN NEW YORK.
THOSE FROM AGES 18 TO 44, THE
FATALITY RATE IS 0.18 PER 1,000
PEOPLE.
WHEN 1/3 OF THE WORKING
POPULATION ARE MADE UP OF
MILLENNIALS, IT MAKES SENSE TO
GET THOSE YOUNGER PEOPLE BACK
OUT THERE TO TRY AND STIMULATE
OUR ECONOMY AGAIN.
STEVE: INDEED.
LET’S SWITCH GEARS, DR. SAPHIER.
LATER TODAY THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT IS GOING TO HEAR ANOTHER
CASE REGARDING LITTLE SISTERS OF
THE POOR VS. PENNSYLVANIA.
REMEMBER, DURING THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT, FOLKS, IT WAS MANDATED
THAT COMPANIES HAD TO PROVIDE
BIRTH CONTROL FOR EMPLOYEES.
BUT LITTLE SISTERS OF THE POOR
SAID THAT FLIES IN THE FACE OF
EVERYTHING WE STAND FOR.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THIS
PORTION, DR. SAPHIER OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IS GOING
BACK TO THE SUPREME COURT, WHAT
DO YOU THINK THAT MEANS FOR THE
ENTIRE ACT?
>> I KNOW THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
EXTRAPOLATE THIS INTO A BIGGER
PICTURE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
THE CONSTITUTIONALITY HAS
ALREADY BEEN UP TO DEBATE
MULTIPLE TIMES.
THIS PARTICULAR CASE IS WHETHER
OR NOT THAT THEY’RE GOING TO
UPHOLD THE TRUMP’S RULINGS.
THEY RULED TO EXPAND RELIGIOUS
FREEDOMS WHEN IT CAME TO THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT SAYING NOT
ONLY WITH CHURCHES EXEMPT BUT
CERTAIN RELIGIOUS NONPROFITS
WERE EXEMPT AND NOW EVEN FOR
PROFITS WERE EXEMPT.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER WHY HEALTH
INSURANCE WAS MADE INITIALLY
ABOUT A CENTURY AGO.
IT WAS A MEANS TO ENTICE
EMPLOYEES FROM WORKING UNDER A
PARTICULAR EMPLOYER.
AT ONE POINT, WE SHOULD PROBABLY
BE RESPECTING THE FREEDOM OF
SAID EMPLOYER AND WHAT THEY WANT
TO OFFER TO THEIR EMPLOYEE.
IF THEY ARE NOT OFFERING BIRTH
CONTROL OR SOMETHING OF THAT
THAT THE EMPLOYEE WANTS, THEN IT
IS THE EMPLOYEE’S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE WHETHER THEY WANT TO BE
EMPLOYED THERE RIGHT NOW, WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
JOBS WHO NEED PEOPLE TO WORK FOR
THEM.
IT’S NOT THAT THERE ARE A LACK
OF JOBS.
MY PERSONAL OPINION IS I DO
BELIEVE THAT AN EMPLOYER SHOULD
BE ABLE TO OFFER WHAT THEY WANT,
IT SHOULDN’T BE THE GOVERNMENT
SAYING WHAT THEY HAVE TO.
BUT IT’S ALSO THE RIGHT OF THE
EMPLOYEE OR THE PERSON WHO IS
TRYING TO VET FOR THAT JOB
WHETHER THEY ARE GOING TO EVEN
APPLY FOR THAT JOB.
STEVE: YERP, EXACTLY.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO LISTEN TO THE
ORAL ARGUMENTS ONCE AGAIN LIVE.
THE SUPREME COURT WILL BE
STREAMING IT.
ALL PART OF MAKING AMERICA
HEALTHY AGAIN WHICH IS A BOOK ON
YOUR BOOK SHELF RIGHT BEHIND YOU
AND A BOOK ON MY BOOK SHELF AS
WELL CHECK IT OUT "MAKE AMERICA